Now, imagine that we
put X and Y side by side with X in the left and Y on the right, and we view these two systems together
as if they form a single compound system.
to give this new system a name, we can write it as an
ordered pair like this, or we can just juxtapose
the two letters like this.
These are both common and we
can pick whichever one we want or whichever one is more convenient.
Either way, we'll read it as XY.
A very natural question
to ask at this point is what are the classical states of this new compound system XY?
And the answer to that question is that the classical state set of XY is the Cartesian product of
the two classical state sets,
sigma and gamma, which you
can see defined right here.
At a given moment, X has some classical state
which is an element of sigma, and Y has some classical state
which is an element of gamma,
and we're simply thinking
about these two states together as if they form a single state, and that's precisely the notion
that the Cartesian product captures. We have have two elements,
one from each of our sets, and we want to think about
these two elements together
as if they form a single
element from a single set.
To be clear, there is an assumption here which is that we know
which one of our systems is X and which one is Y,
and there's no confusion between them. It's not important that X is physically on the left hand
side and Y is on the right,
but rather that the two
systems are distinguishable and that we've decided
to order them this way just so that we can keep
straight which one is which.
Here's a very simple example where sigma is the binary alphabet and gamma is the set
containing the four card suits.
If X stores a binary value and Y stores one of the four card suits, then there are eight
possible classical states
of the pair XY, which you
can see listed right here.
For more than two systems, this generalizes in a straightforward way.
In particular if X1 through Xn are systems having classical
state sets sigma one through sigma n respectively.
Then if we imagine grouping
the n systems together and viewing them as one system, the classical state set is
given by the Cartesian product
of the n classical state sets
sigma one through sigma n.
As you can see right here on the screen. The Cartesian product
can be defined like this for any number of sets.
For example, if we have three systems and they all share the binary alphabet as their classical state set, so in other words we have three bits,
then there are eight
possible classical states of the three bits viewed
together as a single system and you can see them listed right here.
Each system individually can
be in the state zero or one, and we range over all of
the possible combinations.
An n-tuple of classical states can alternatively be written as a string where we drop the
parentheses and the comma like you see right here.
And this is particularly sensible when we think about
classical states as symbols as in the very common example
of the binary alphabet
that we keep coming back to. Sometimes it's very convenient to do this and it tends to make
our expressions simpler
and less cluttered. The notion of a string is in fact formalized
in mathematical terms through carte and products,
so this is really just
an alternative notation and not something conceptually different.
As an example, let's say that we have
10 bits X1 through X10.
That means that the classical state set of the 10 bits together,
which you might naturally think about as a 10 bit register
in a computer for example,
is the tenfold Cartesian
product of the binary alphabet with a self.
And if we write those states like strings, they look like you see right
here, there's 1,024 of them,
so of course they're not all listed here. These three dots right here
are supposed to indicate that there's a pattern that you can deduce
and hopefully you get the idea. Now there's a convention
that we're going to follow for ordering the the elements
of Cartesian product sets,
and it's important to
clarify this for the sake of representing both probabilistic states and quantum states as vectors.
The convention is that
we order the elements of Cartesian product
sets lexicographically, which basically just
means dictionary ordering.
To be more specific, we start with the assumption that each of the individual sets that we're taking the Cartesian product of already has its own ordering
and we think about a
given n-tuple or a string as if it's a word and we
order them alphabetically.
Another way to say this is that the positions within
an n-tuple or a string decrease in significance
from left to right,
just like when we write numbers using the digits zero through nine.
Here's an example that's
meant to clarify this.
If we take the Cartesian product between the sets containing
one, two, and three and the binary alphabet, we get a set containing six elements
and here they're listed in the
order that's being described.
All of the elements with a
one in the first position come before all of the elements with a two in the first position and they come before all of the elements